but pristine beaches and crystal-clear
waters of the Caribbean may be unrivaled
the world over nearly 4 million people a
year travel from the u.s. to Cancun for
vacation each year another 2 million
from other countries including Europe
and Canada but all of that is now under
threat from the newest manifestation of
a changing planet seaweed it is the
biggest algae bloom in the world massive
waves of seaweed called Sargassum
washing up on shore day after day this
Beach was just cleaned today yes a
couple of hours and they say we will be
on the beach again
Jose Escalante has owned a small hotel
in Tulum Mexico for 8 years every day
workers here and up and down the Yucatan
Peninsula removed tons and tons of
decomposing Sargassum from beaches every
night
it comes back Rosa Rodriguez Martinez
from Mexico's national university is
trying to figure out why we are getting
Sargassum almost from March to October
so basically more than half of the year
we receive massive amounts whereas
before it was how long before maybe 2 or
3 weeks during the summer that's a huge
difference
yes it's impressive impressive is one
word for it a problem big problem is
another it's a problem economical
problem ecological and probably human
health problem also since 2011 the
amount of Sargassum in the Atlantic has
increased dramatically
it currently forms a 5,000 mile mass
from Africa to the Caribbean it is
estimated to weigh 22 million tons why
is it so bad right now I think it's
because we have polluted they see too
much so now we have a lot of nutrients
and the algae are taking advantage of it
fertilizer runoff from Brazil increased
by deforestation is believed to be the
largest fuel source for the Sargassum
that combined with warming ocean water
and changing ocean currents has put the
Yucatan squarely in the crosshairs
it has gotten so bad the Mexican Navy
has just been put in charge of dealing
with this problem they took us up on a
reconnaissance mission to locate the
largest Sargassum waves it's the most
romantic ancien we're fully aware that
we were only addressing the effects of
Sargassum rear admiral enrique flores
morado told us the navy will build new
Sargassum busting ships to reel in as
much as they can but that does not solve
any problem in reality the causes have
to be addressed but given the lack of
research we're now implementing
immediate actions right now many towns
and resort owners are using floating
barriers to corral and collect Sargassum
including in puerto morelos half an hour
south of Cancun we can say for sure that
we are the first destination in the
whole Mexican Caribbean with already a
control above the cerveza there's a lot
of it though yeah yeah because this area
we are it doesn't look control no no
Hector to Maya it's in charge of tourism
here how many trucks go in and out each
day tomorrow down 50 more than 50 jobs
just of Sargassum every day carted it in
a heavier and then we just start mixing
that with this ragazzo some are
developing novel ways to use Sargassum
including Omar Vasquez who's building
homes with it they're better than the
other brakes the Sargassum is mixed with
clay and compost by foot and then
compressed into bricks
I mean it's ironic because I grew up
without a house without at home we occur
as a border to the states when I would
say beer sold and then came back I came
back to leave my Mexican dream your
Mexican dream yes
does it have not even a gram of cement
everything is organic
even though Vasquez says his homes are
100% organic there may be an issue with
what accumulates in the Sargassum at sea
Rosa Rodriguez's latest research shows
Sargassum is high in heavy metals like
lead and arsenic and disposal is a major
issue this is one of the places we found
where the Sargassum is taken it's a dump
site miles into the jungle far away from
the ocean
it's unclear if the Sargassum left here
seeps into the ground goes up into the
air or just sits here forever Sargassum
is either being dumped inland or buried
under the beach which is illegal it is a
crisis stretching across the Caribbean
with no end in sight for folks watching
this who may not be familiar with this
problem or what's happening here what do
you say it's something that is happening
to the world not just to the region this
is just a consequence of the entire
planet being you know in in trouble
could we see this washing ashore in
Florida South Carolina Georgia
potentially yeah I mean it's worse in
the Yucatan right now in some other
islands in the Caribbean but yeah
potentially if it increases going to
this area for years and you just watch
it gets slowly worse and worse every
year and just frightening that they try
to dispose of it but as you were showing
it the piece I was thinking but if it
seeps into the groundwater if it goes
into the air you're still not getting
rid of nobody knows what to do with it
right now really and it continues I open
really really good report yes thank you